au sahel c'est véronique du caire qui
est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est que tout le monde se l'arraché 1
véronique on voit sur tous les plateaux
moi je vous ai vu dans le top 50 dame si
vous avez été un de mes moments préférés
à mais je vous le temps peut remercier
adoré faire
batmag guignols oui on commence avec
isabelle boulay part de moi je ne sais
plus comment tuer mais ni comment te
parler on parle de moi au par la balle à
moi
et donc je me suis dit véronique ça
pourrait peut-être est intéressant de
mélanger tout ça donc de prendre ma voix
d'une chanteuse mais de la faire chanter
dans un corps d'une autre chanteuse
on va faire chanter vanessa mais dans le
corps de céline dion sur les taxis y va
tout
je
chien
[Musique]
que tout était faux pas
key
on ne peut pas faire d'annoncé
[Applaudissements]
à
en alsace on hasardeuse l'amour la joie
de la bonne humeur à mon bonheur
je crevais l'avant sur la voie de la raf
a bien dans le corps de teena tenue je
tiens
[Musique]
cela
du sud
attention aux patients une petite
vanessa par année ok ma folie mon envie
à lui dit mon idée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la fuite m
le rendu du caire qui est avec nous
[Musique]